هذه قصه مؤلمه لعائله سوريه استقرت في
مدينه مرسين التركيه منذ ثمان سنوات هي
عائله حيان الكل يسكنون مجمعا سكنيا واحدا
في المدينه سليمان حياني الشقيق الاصغر
لدي طفل عمره 12 عاما خرج للبقاليه لشراء
بعض الاغراض وتاخر لساعات فتلقى عمه هذه
الصوره للطفل من رقم دولي ورساله تطالبه
بدفع فديه قدرها 200 الف دولار امريكي
ومثلهم باليورو المهله فقط ثلاثه ايام
توجه الاهل للشرطه فتبين من كاميرات
مراقبه ان الطفل
لم يكن قد غادر المجمع السكني هذا وجه
الشكوك نحو حارس العقار حارس المجمع بعد
ساعات من تلك الرساله عثرت الشرطه على جثه
الطفل في قبو المجمع السكني الذي يسكن فيه
وهذه مشاهد من تشييع الطفل
لا اله الا الله مشاهد الله لا اله الا
الله نشاهد
لا اله الا الله اشاهد
لا اله الا الله واشاهد حبيب الله
ويشاهد حبيب الله لا اله الا الله
قبضت الشرطه على حارس الامن واعترف انه
خنق الطفل حتى الموت خوفا من اكتشاف امره
بعد اختطافه وبعد معرفه بان الوالد والد
الطفل ابلغ الشرطه وفق مواقع تركيه كيف
علق المغردون على حادثه مقتل الطفل السوري
خالد حياني فيروس حسن قالت لك لازم نتعلم
نحن السوريين عشان ما حدا يتعرض لهيك
مصيبه انه ما نصرح بعملنا الحقيقي ابدا
خاصه اللي بيبين انه مرتاحين ماديا جدا
والافضل اللي بده يفتح مشروع غني يفتحوا
بعيد عن منطقه السكن علي ايكوش يقول لك
سرعه كشف الشرطه لتفاصيل القضيه دليل على
احترافياتها نتمنى من القضاء ان يسرع ايضا
في الحكم على القاتل حتى تتحقق العداله
تقول حزينه لتعرض واحده من اجمل عائلات
سوريا في مدينتنا
الموقف الصعب اياكن الله في عونهم
ولتسرع دولتنا في مواساتهم بمحاسبه قاتل
ابنهم شعبان سنان اوغلو قال لك في هذه
التغريده بعض وسائل الاعلام غير الناضجه
تركزوا على جنسيه القاتل وجنسيه الضحيه
وهذا غير معقول نحن عشنا مع بعضنا في هذه
المدينه كاخوه منذ سنوات ومستعدون لذلك كل
الوقت منذ عام
2003 الغت تركيا عقوبه الاعدام من قانونها
لذا لا يتوقع ان يعدم القاتل واقصى عقوبه
قد يواجهها الحارس اذا ما ثبتت التهمه
عليه هي السجن لاربعين عاما بتهمتي الخطف
والقتل